so in the US all these changes took
place mostly in the first half of the
20th century a little beyond and so
they're basically invisible to us now
which is why we look at our food system
and we think it's normal but we're
actually seeing a lude system that is
completely distorted by refrigeration
and what's interesting is if you go to a
place that has only just refrigerated or
is still refrigerating you can see those
shifts take place which is why I went to
China to visit the the the factory of
the frozen dumpling mogul who brought
frozen food to China this is the frozen
dumpling Factory he was the surgeon and
wen dong shopping said oh you know some
people are going to get rich this
surgeon decided he would like to be one
of those and so he harvested some parts
from some of the hospital machinery and
built a freezer system he was already
famous in the neighborhood for his
homemade dumplings and he just started a
a dumpling factory but what's amazing is
when you go there you can see the same
things play out that played out here so
there was an issue
initially a very intense distrust and
there still is amongst a certain
generation when I talk to folks about
could could refrigerated in frozen food
be good could it really be okay and and
the frozen dumpling mogul told me that
actually the drip right there on the
dumpling is very important that
signified freshness they tried to sell
the dumplings in a in a package without
the drip and and they weren't selling
and the drips somehow sort of
communicated of freshness to folks you
can I visited people who are we who are
breeding Chinese vegetables to be cold
storage tolerant so their vegetables are
changing in real-time their diets are
changing where things are grown is
changing this is a big Chinese
government project called the south to
north vegetable transfer that is
shifting
where things are grown these are Chinese
apples going out to the world it's
changing where where food is sold so wet
markets are turning into Walmart's and
that changes how often people shop it
changes the layout of their houses it
changes the layout of cities so you
could see all of those things kind of
changing in real-time and what's crazy
about China is so in 2010 the Chinese
government's a made refrigeration part
of their 12th five-year plan they were
like we are going to refrigerate and
being China they just did it and so it
has in the past 10 years the amount of
refrigerated space in China has grown by
more than 20 times it is is just
exploded and yet still Chinese people
have less than a third of the cold
storage space of a average American per
capita so it's still happening and it's
happening now in India and it's
happening with Chinese funding in Africa
so the world is refrigerating at speed
and a lot of people are like well this
is a good thing right because diets
improve people have access to fresh
vegetables and dairy and more animal
protein that's exciting
farmers are not stuck selling all their
harvests when it comes in they can
export they can make money they can they
don't and and and then the big thing
that people say is will food waste right
when you don't have a cold chain you
lose a lot of food so in a country like
India where there isn't a robust cold
chain and estimates are that a that at
least 40% is lost before it you know at
the farm stage basically before it ever
gets anywhere close to the consumer in
America where we have an amazing cold
chain well we waste 40 percent on the
consumer end so the cold chain people
refrigeration boosters like to say it
prevents food waste but I think it's a
little more nuanced than that it kind of
just shifts where it happens and maybe
makes it easier to fix I don't
maybe not this actually strikes me as
harder to fix in a lot of ways
[Music]